foreign
good day
who's it done
hey Malaika
how are you doing sorry my microphone is
a bit
weird today
hello everyone hello random citizen
is
foreign
sorry if I mispronounce
your name I'm I'm terrible with names
hey vilda
Matilda Christensen are you Scandinavian
by any chance
uh I'm just gonna play the game this is
a new save so I haven't done much
at all
as you can see I've only got four Hearts
I only have so I I transferred all my my
save files to
Yuzu
don't strike me Nintendo
it's a legal dump of the game
I think the last thing I did I think I
made this new save because uh I wanted
to to capture footage of the
cutscenes inside the dungeons
because I already did like all of that a
long time ago so for the last video for
the wind Temple
hey Adam how are you doing
got any videos for us tonight
shoot they're on to us I think I'm
I was on the verge of going into the
depths with unobo
I think I have to fight that thing on
top of the
on top of the mountain
I was just about to start playing tears
of the Kingdom again second playthrough
this has to be my third or fourth Maybe
although I kind of do it like
sporadically for mostly for capturing
stuff
so when I figure out oh shoot I don't
have anything like I cannot trigger this
specific cutscene anymore on my main
save
I will go into this one
and then at some point I'm gonna have I
will have done a lot of stuff on this
save too and I will have to start a new
one again
taking a writing break
that's a good that's always a good idea
man
I took a two-month writing break to heal
up
I've been messing around with Yuzu a lot
today to get better quality footage
because my next video is gonna
incorporate a lot of mixed footage
between breath of the wild from simu
obviously an emulator because I have a
free cam there
and uh tears of the Kingdom but tears of
the Kingdom no it looks noticeably worse
because I don't have all I didn't have
all the mods installed and all that
stuff
but now I do and it looks considerably
better I don't have a free cam yet
because I don't think one exists but
tears of the Kingdom just yet or if they
do they're behind a paywall or
just the basic stuff like a first person
mod so I can just capture stuff without
having Link in the shot
uh infinite stamina so I can just
you know sail around without having to
worry about stamina infinite hearts
just all the basic stuff I was
considering just playing the Yuzu
version tonight but I I don't know if
that's a good idea considering what
happened to to uh what's his name Point
Crow getting his whole Channel stricken
you know but I I do value quality
footage
and I just cannot always get the footage
I want from the normal game so I have to
use emulators it's just how it is
I try to be a good little boy and dump
my own ROM
and my own firmware and all that stuff
so it's it's legal but you know how
Nintendo be
how long do you plan to stream tonight
uh just I guess uh
two hours or something
I said one or two hours to my fiance so
we'll see I'm going on a small trip
tomorrow
just get out of because
even though I've not been uploading for
two months I haven't done anything I
haven't been able to to travel or do
anything really
so I forgot how do I beat this guy again
and I just
uh no I have to actually climb up
this is very not Zelda music
it's like
if you put a proper beat under it it's
like a techno song
I have I don't have any I've done
aside from the opening shrines on the on
the sky oh God
like I have not done any shrines at all
do I even have the flame breaker armor
okay I do at least I got that going for
me
uh
I forgot how to
does anyone remember how to beat this
guy
I forgot if you have to climb up or
something
it's been a while
Wing glider
did I miss the winged glider
yes I did
man his aim is terrible
I just passed it let me see
oh there we go
geez I was not paying attention
okay there we go I remember this part
being very easy
oh that well there we go
I am not good at video games
[Music]
okay
got him
I was actually planning to capture
footage while doing this but I don't
know if that's going to be possible
I'm already so bad at multitasking
damn
but yeah I'm working on my zone Ice
sheika video
oh
there we go
it's gonna be a be a fun video to work
on it's just gonna be another big
project of course because I I cannot do
shorter videos it's just
impossible
first time playing no no no I've
finished it like two three times now
this is technically my fourth
playthrough but
I don't think I've beaten Ganondorf four
times in total
what's my favorite thing about tears of
the Kingdom ah
probably the depths
if I had to choose
and just the the general gameplay
I'm glad you're back man it was so weird
there was so much pre-release hype and
then 50 of Zelda tubers just randomly
fell off the map for like three months
well in my case it really was just due
to health issues
like I I started having
really really terrible
like abdominal pain which just it was
impossible to ignore and it really
sapped my energy and
went to the doctor got blood tests done
of course I didn't find anything it's
just IBS or IBD or some some
like that it's really annoying
I had it last year as well
except this year was a bit it went on
for a bit longer than I
that that I hoped
and it just really didn't work for me at
least when I tried to work I would just
make it worse because stress usually
makes it worse
uh let's see let's see let's see
where's you no boy oh
there's a light Road
what do you want from the depth
civilization well I do I think it's a
bit of a shame that they didn't flesh
out the depths as much like all the
buildings kind of look the same almost
feels pretty maybe it is procedurally
generated
although it does have the same
geography as Hyrule above but like
inverted so maybe not
it it just feels too repetitive to me
they could have done a little bit more
with it but you know
it is what it is
I personally have IBD which causes me to
get more cultures than the average
person when I'm stressed
yeah well that's that's basically the
case uh with me as well
it was just unbearable at some like some
days it was so it was so bad
all I wanted to do was sleep because at
least when you're asleep you don't feel
pain
but I'm I'm glad I took the two months
off to heal but it did like my channel
did take quite the nosedive
like my my subscriber growth just went
from like
7K subscribers for 28 days to like 900
like you you're gone for two months and
it's just it everything just collapses
in on itself
YouTube is not a very forgiving employer
but you know it is what it is I'm it's
already starting to climb again and as
soon as I get a few videos up I'm sure
it's gonna be back to
back to business
the question is now what is next for
Zelda what's gonna happen now are we
gonna be waiting for another six years
are we gonna get
2D zeldas or we're gonna get more
remakes
like if Nintendo's coming out with a new
system
like maybe next year or something I'm
very curious what they're gonna do oh
wait I I have to do this if it's even
possible is it possible no
I don't think so
I don't think no you cannot activate it
while crouched I think you can only do
it at the uh the other statues
the unknown species that we don't still
don't know what they are
although they kind of look like gecks
do I have any yeah I do have light roots
I'm collecting some lost souls
where's your nobo
where the heck did that guy go
I should have had more stamina
I think this will probably curse me
right okay will it oh no it doesn't
they should just fully remake Ocarina of
Time in Majora's Mask in one giant game
I might be getting old though
well I mean they they they're still
great games so
although I'm not really a fond of remix
anymore I'm getting a bit tired of it
sometimes it's nice like I played Dead
Space remake recently while I was
healing I played a lot of just games
that I haven't played before played
alien isolation but like uh dead space I
never finished that game back when it
came out don't know why
maybe I got stuck or just didn't have to
pay the the patience but now I redeem
myself and I finished the whole game
oh that's a statue pointing that way am
I going the wrong way
let's get on top of this hill first if I
can even make it with this stamina
get away from me
oh I have terrible weapons too uh
personally your videos have helped me
through really rough about of depression
and move across the country
and and a move across the country I
thought lucky you had uh you had to move
across the country like you mean like
you moved house or
because that can be very stressful
but yeah nice to hear that I could
help with with the content
I felt really bad for not being able to
upload for so long
uh it is here
like see this is where I feel like they
could have done a little bit more the
the zonai architecture it all looks the
same so
gorandia does it doesn't even though
they call it this the lost city of
garandia it doesn't really feel like a
city there's no like houses or
things that you would have
that would fit with a civilization
actually living here
oh hey it's orange and Samuel
how you doing
foreign
still alive and more slash immortal
once you beat him for the final time
I'd love to see more about more of him
in the DLC or whatever is next I think
we're probably gonna get DLC for this I
I totally forgot about DLC actually
that's we're probably gonna get that
first before we get anything new
although
I'm not holding my breath when it comes
to how expensive it will be
like if
Champions ballot was anything to go by
it's probably not going to be like on
the same level as torna
monolith soft just
does things differently when it comes to
DLC it's just basically just a new game
but Nintendo doesn't really do that
at least not with Zelda so far
do you think the December amiibo will
come with DLC that that's possible
I'm not really an amiibo guy although I
do have a giant link amiibo now
oh wait I have two Lin because I did do
the wind tempo
that's probably the most played sound
effect
like even when I'm when I'm asleep I
still hear
that sound effect just you I I use
tulins
tornado so much
when I'm playing
there we go the last last goranda They
Don't Really necessarily call it a city
here at least
so either it's just a mining operation
another mining as if they didn't have
enough mines down here
but I remember someone's calling it a
lost city but maybe that's one of the
dialogues
I'd have to go into the text dump
to see
where's your nobo
did he tell me where to go
did I just go completely in the wrong
direction or is he just somewhere at the
entrance
man it's been a while
even though the game came out like four
months ago
oh he was at the first light route oh no
so I walked all the way over here for
nothing
I have to do it again
ah
I'm an idiot I might as well activate
some other light Roots Maybe
the music's pretty good in this dungeon
yeah it's good to be back
nice to be working on things at uh after
such a long time
yeah the fire temple music is uh I used
it quite a lot in my like yeah that was
my previous video
I think
also the lightning dungeon one I also
use that one
for a huge section of the video
try using a hoverbike I don't even know
if I have Ultra no I don't even have an
ultra hand yet like this is I started
this save just to capture footage of
the Stormwind Arc
and that whole mission
that's the whole reason I started this
I skipped all the shrines I skipped all
the optional stuff which is like 99 of
the game basically
I went back to playing breath wild for a
moment just to fight moscoshier again
awesome fight and love the reward yeah
yeah MOS kosher was pretty damn cool
he's probably the coolest boss in the
whole game
and it's not even the base game so
oh I'm not gonna make that not with this
not with one stamina wheel
you know what I'm just gonna warp back I
think I activated this light root so
yeah we should be good
let's get you Nova over here
when's the shika zonai video gonna drop
um well I'm going on a TR on a like a
few days trip few day trip tomorrow
I've already done a lot of preparation
I've done some animation stuff I've
captured some footage got used working
properly
um
I have a lot of notes
like a lot of notes
and I think I wrote the
the first few paragraphs yeah I did I
did write the first few paragraphs but
there's there there's a lot of notes
it's gonna be a long video so I guess
not next week but the week after
I am thinking about maybe starting to
like upload shorts
I don't know if that's someone like
something people would be interested in
but there's quite a lot of few little
details and tears of the Kingdom that
aren't really
suitable for a full video
so maybe I could finally pick up shorts
because I I've been thinking about doing
it for a while
but I I don't know I guess it never
came to fruition
you know it's a good way to have like
little mini fairies
because I don't really do like eight
minute videos where it's just with a lot
of padding I just or like even 10 minute
videos with a lot of padding I just
don't like doing it I like working on
bigger videos
the big stuff something that at least
has some substance to it
so shorts would be a nice way to do it I
already have some ideas that I've
written down just small little theories
small little things
how many are you
why did they make it the a button it's
the worst the worst choice they could
have made
I better I don't even have any meals
while we're doing we're going hard mode
on this one
I should probably cook something up soon
although I don't even have that many
ingredients to be honest uh
don't even really have mushrooms
I'm surprised they haven't announced
like a master mode yet for this game
tooling is a sage I use the most and
he's so annoying sometimes he blows away
all the Zona capsules yeah I've seen the
memes when the game just came out
it was good to see that everyone was
having the same problems it wasn't just
me
[Music]
should we have it on the map yeah I'm
going the right way
actually if I warp will he come with me
I don't really wanna
find out
maybe I shouldn't do it
oh he will
okay I'm gonna trust you
snooze poos I'm gonna that's a great
name by the way
I'm trusting you
who knew rivali would be replaced with a
Pinecone
what does that mean
oh
uh yeah let's go this way
uh did you check out the
uh Gerudo Quest that reveals the
identity of the hero yes I did and I was
very disappointed
like very very disappointed
not because it wasn't what I predicted
because I I really I'd rather be
surprised than having guessed something
right like if they came up with
something really smart where I was like
oh man I didn't even think about that
but no
it was just some dude
and the other heroines were not sages
they were just seven gruda Warriors
grew to warrior women and I'm like what
then why did you put seven sages on the
statues
like you can't like did some intern just
put that there as a joke and didn't tell
anyone else that they did
Nintendo really has to keep track of
their own lore like the lore that they
established sometimes because it was so
infuriating
well the eighth heroine was either that
hero guy
the the the
you know zonai link
or or raru or someone else
but it was some male hero some undefined
male hero
I think it should still should have been
Zelda but
in general I do have to say even though
it is a great game I do think that
because the lore in this game is a lot
more it's not as big as it was in breath
of the Wild
which is I think also why you haven't
seen that many theories from other
creators so far
again doesn't mean the game is is bad
but lore wise did there just wasn't that
much to discover here
as opposed to breath of the wild where
it was just a huge new Hyrule
completely unfamiliar all these
buildings all these ruins to choose from
and
there was just so much more to talk
about with this one it's
I don't know there's just less to it
because it's
it's a sequel so it's the same world
again
maybe we'll get more lore in the DLC
yeah or or a book if they do another
creating a champion kind of deal
creating a sage
I should actually I don't think he will
tell me that I should go to uh the guy I
interviewed for the for the books the
guy who's who did the localization of
creating a champion
I should just try to pry him for answers
see if they're already because they have
to already be working on it if they're
gonna release one one of those books
again they're already working on it
probably
at least on the Japanese version
don't think are related uh
uh sure I think didn't they kind of
confirm that
I think they did
either in one of the books or somewhere
else it says
it does mention ancestry or something
I don't remember where I saw it it was
quite recently uh because someone
mentioned it
yeah they're like very distant
relationships like
they're very distant ancestry or
something I don't know
um I think one of the big things I want
to know is what happened to the zonai
before the series because we only see
rauru and mineral yeah that's
for a game that's all about the zonai we
know pretty
like we know very little about the Zona
actually they already left Hyrule by
that time
we don't know why they left what their
civilization looked like when it was
still
you know thriving
because that's also a bit of a problem
with the sky islands there's not that
much to the like the ruins are all the
same you know
there's not not like a Zona like an
abandoned zonai Village up there it's
all just random buildings
it's strewn about
and you can't pet the dogs that's true
it's it's you know what it's just a
terrible game
it's just a horrible game
that was one of the first things I did
immediately went to the nearest stable
to see if I could pet a dog and when I
found out you couldn't I was like
fujibyashi you
ass you you told us you would put it in
and then you don't you you just didn't
what happened
oh I have terrible weapons
where are you
there we go
dark padding technology
especially because I have a dog and I
know how much they like to get they love
to get pet at least most of them do
mine does
although he prefers to play with balls
and stuff
has anyone made a dog petting mod yet
I think maybe for breath of the wild
they did
but I'm pretty sure not for this game
most of the mods that are available
right now
I think Are all uh more like graphical
upgrades and stuff
there's a few that like the basic stuff
like like I said infinite hearts
infinite stamina cheats basically
huh
yeah
something
I do hope I do personally hope that this
is the last in the era of the wild uh
you know section of Zelda or era
the era of the wild era
I wanna I wanna go somewhere else after
this no more Hyrule please
I can do it do it I think you cannot no
you can't
I don't even remember how I did this the
first time I think I just created
like all those like uh when you use one
of those water spouts
or maybe I made a bridge out of all the
mine carts or something I don't even
remember
I think I created a bridge
out of lava
dried up lava
let's try that
or maybe you don't you don't even need
to
but it is more fun that way
oh why did it why did that one
became a bigger one
all right let's see
hooks
I'm sure this is not how you're supposed
to do it and this is like very
over engineered but
or maybe it is I don't know
I'll be getting back to reading comments
in a moment
up I'm horrible
at doing two two things at the same time
there we go
if he destroyed that bridge I would have
been very very angry
yeah I do miss the old dungeons
dude
come on
I guess he doesn't know how a bridge
works
nope
oh my God please you know about just
here I go
what what are you doing
I you know I'll just
that's one way to do it
the sage just sucked except maybe toolin
well toolin is just he's lucky
because his abilities by far the most
helpful one
mineral sucks for sure
I thought she was so underwhelming I was
like yeah I get to to ride a giant Mech
really awesome
but yeah
she's pretty weak
and slow
yeah the music is great
absolutely
this was the worst dungeon in my opinion
it was all cheatable I think most of
them are quite cheatable right
I don't know I I kind of like the
Aesthetics of it and and the music but
that's it's not like the greatest
dungeon ever for sure
but none of the dungeons in this game
are like really something to write home
about to be honest
they were
a small step up
from the Divine Beast I guess
oh oh
what is he doing
ready to go
you know bro
why are you on the back
you're supposed to be in front
oh there he goes
and of course my bow breaks
uh let's see
I do remember doing a lot of climbing in
this dungeon the first time but I barely
have any stamina so I don't think I'm
gonna be able to do that this time
oh wait I have to use him
sure you can
go
I don't think I have any weapons to
cool these guys down
oh just get away from me
oh yeah
oh
he lowered it again
I can just use you know bro
there we go
I also also I'm curious what you guys
think about this but
when I found out the first time that all
the dungeons were gonna be like Co-op
between you and the sages I was a little
bit disappointed I was like man I I
prefer it to just
go inside these labyrinths on my own
just figure it out by myself you know
it ended up not being as bad as I
thought it would but still the fact that
you don't have the option to just go go
in alone
uh
maybe I'm just complaining too much
I just don't like AI companions in in
general unless they're like really not
intrusive or if they're like a huge part
of the the story itself
like obviously the last of us would not
be the same without Ellie
who is
also an AI partner
uh can I make a bridge again or should I
make a bridge again
heck we're just gonna make another
Bridge
hey Speedy duck
the spirit one was technically alone
yeah yeah
I think that's the first one I did
and I still still felt like man no don't
come with me I'll handle this I got this
read you thanks for your help back at
the
Guru town
leave me be
I miss the traditional Zelda companions
like midnight as low
Etc midna yes
as low
uh
I used to like eslo for his personality
but then I put replayed Minish Cap again
and I was like man I forgot how much
this guy
talks
he just constantly
like interrupts the gameplay even to
give you hints where things like you
didn't even ask for
like people complain about Navi
sometimes like obviously also it's also
a bit of a meme but at least Navi was
pretty unintrusive like aside from maybe
the beginning
like the Deku Tree when you're you're
first
like most of the dungeon and stuff she's
she's pretty quiet
of course she did have her moments too
where she's like man it's so cold in
here it's like yeah I know
thank you for your input Navi
Bridge
didn't they test it out how many things
you can stack on top of each other
like make a huge
like stick Tower
I remember seeing a few of those videos
I don't think unobo is gonna
nope of course not because he doesn't
know what a bridge is
and I think if I
look at this cannot even take him up
onto my my perfect bridge that I created
I think the yeah the thing is here
oh dead
I should get some food
I don't have any food
why is an island in the sky called water
temple uh beats me man I have no idea
uh is my bridge still hitting no oh I
destroyed my bridge too
well at least I got to do that
oh I could have just crossed like that
again I'm not very good at video games
sometimes I am I have my moments
uh
do I just have to create a bridge again
or
don't think I can make that right
link doesn't jump that far
maybe he
recall oh yeah that's another that's an
idea I I forgot I have recall
but then you know boys not gonna be here
again
good call by the way on recall
it's the one ability I always forget I
have
got him
oh he just
manifests out of nowhere
he'll follow you up to the other side
yeah only when you're not looking
you'll just suddenly manifest out of
like thin air
I mean to each the uh each their own I
mean the water temple
I just don't think it should have been
called the water temple because it had
very little to do with water you know
most people so far at least from what
I've seen
think the water tempo is the weakest one
and as for favorites I think most people
like the wind Temple the most
or maybe the gurudo one
I like the lead up to the water temple
the ancient Zora Waterworks was pretty
cool and the music down there is really
awesome too
it was just cool to see that there
really was something
like at the bottom of the lake East
Reservoir Lake
no not that way
huh
I want to use a one-handed weapon or a
spear
there we go
two-handed weapons are so slow
can we theorize about what the hell uh
Goro means I think Goro means dude or
or friend or something like that
just a little catchphrase
and to think I wanted to try to capture
footage I don't think I'm gonna be doing
that tonight
yeah Goro is like bro
I said dude but that's more like a 90s
thing it's bro now plus dude is more for
Stoners right
dude
there we go
I also have not upgraded
any of my stashes at all
so my choices are very limited
uh
uh nor my battery so we are really doing
hard mode
self-imposed hard mode
Goro actually is a
something for rolling
in Japanese
yeah but I don't know if they also say
it in Japanese do they
do they say like a Goro equivalent or
because they so they do invent some
things for the English versions
can I go up here
can I please let me
why not
is that like anti-cheating
come on uh
you can just climb it I guess
game over Jesse hello man
it's the equivalent of saying sun in
Japanese or sir in English
I see
I see I see
I actually appreciated how silly the
Water Temple boss fight was even though
it's the most annoying boss
yeah I I thought it was the boss fight
didn't really bother me it was just too
short
all the dungeons are short but that one
felt like unreasonably short because you
can just parasail around very very
easily this place at least has a lot of
floors
but again the lead up to it was pretty
cool
I remember watching a Zelda fairy video
where it is mentioned that they say Goro
in Japanese
they didn't say Goro in English in
breakfast no
I don't remember oh
I don't remember that saying them saying
that
daru definitely never said Goro
seems and seems like a unovo thing
because he's younger you know so he's
he's using the young people language
because you don't see people above 40
calling each other bro in real life
either
you know about definitely did say it in
brex world yeah yeah but the Rook didn't
neither does Pluto
I think he said it in
age of Calamity as well which you know
Canon not canon it is the same voice
actor
oh I remember this one
gotta build a ramp
uh
come here
it was ad-libbed ah
The Rook was a boomer
you know most gen Z yeah that is true
yeah
agreed
The Rook was cool though
I liked the Rope
actually huh
do I have anything oh yeah
I'm gonna use one of the mine carts as
the base
see if that works
so you gotta make that I feel like it's
not steep enough
and that's yeah
barely
let's just try it
huh
I don't think that's that like I think
they tweaked the physics a little bit to
give you uh you know a little
leeway
let's keep it up Goro
The Rook is the rock Uncle do you think
the Rook listens to rock
like hard rock
I feel like he would
uh let's see
oh there's another entrance here
I have to build another ramp
I can grab my notes for my zonai video
later on maybe list a few off
see if you guys have anything to add or
change to it
Goro
that one he also barely made it
uh
I do think it's really cool how the
music changes based on your progression
they didn't really do that in the older
games
I hope they do that in future dungeons
too
I just hope they will be a lot bigger
and maybe a little bit more traditional
I mostly watch Point Crow does he still
do stuff or did he kind of will not give
up but
I guess he he did he was severely
demoralized by the whole situation right
I would be for sure all my all my work
all my stuff that I did just destroyed
I'm not going to make that
he still does tears to the kingdom
videos oh he does
with mods or without it
I should watch his stuff again sometime
I usually watch Croton because obviously
because I know Croton kinda I don't
really know know him but you know he has
worked with me on a video Once
and I've talked to him a couple of times
he's a he's a nice guy
I think he did a video not too long ago
about beating the game with only grudo
gear
please let me yeah yes
yeah Croton is very wholesome
nice guy
he's good friends with Nintendo black
crisis as well
also a very wholesome guy by the way
bro bro really really needs life of a
vocabulin too
I know
I know I will do it at some point I
guess
I just really don't have any inspiration
for it right now oh I have motion
controls on I forgot about that I turned
them off for Yuzu because I use it to
you know Pan the camera around you don't
want to have that
yeah Moxie as well
sometimes I hate Nintendo I think most
people sometimes hate Nintendo and then
we love them again when they put out a
good game
we tolerate Nintendo as a company
we love their games we tolerate the
company
uh is there more up here
actually I
should just check the map
oh there is one is it it's either
down or up
can I just
yeah it's all the way at the bottom it
seems
yeah it's at the bottom
uh maybe you should I should get the one
on top first thing because I'm already
on the same level once I drop down I'm
not sure if I'm going to be able to get
back up again
uh
it's in that building over there I think
yeah
somewhere over there
I'm not sure if I can
I don't even know if I can get there
from here
there is a hole in the ground here
but how do I get in
probably from the bottom
you know what I'll just get the other
one first
oh
wrong power
I feel bad for the devs they're probably
overworked as well
uh maybe I'm not sure if they were
crunching for this one they did take six
years to make it I don't I don't feel
like it had the same kind of pressure
behind it but who knows
I'm not a Game Dev
they had close to six years
because the game they were already
working on it when it was announced
all right let's see
can I cheese this somehow
I think I can yeah
it's on the top floor right yeah I see I
see you
can I use tool in here yeah I can
I don't think I was able to use Tulin
the first time I played this because I
did the wind tempo as one of the final
ones I think third or something
which was a mistake that was a mistake I
I did the uh Guru Gerudo dungeon first
with
five Hearts I think five or six
and the the final boss is actually
really hard if you only have like five
or six hearts
like Queen give though is no joke
probably one of the more challenging
bosses in the game
uh
you know I'll just go for it
yeah I'm not gonna make that
I want to see if I can climb it
I think I can even with this stamina I
should be able to cheese this
muktarak is just annoying
yeah someone else said
the same thing that he's annoying
huh
I should be able to make this right
I just want to cheese it it's more fun
that way
rocket Shields are your best friend here
yeah
I don't think I have any Rockets right
now
I think I barely have any any Zone eye
Parts yeah
and I don't have Ultra hand so I cannot
I think I did have like uh Ultra hand
and I I used a lot of the uh the super
spring in this dungeon
the super spring is really helpful
well we've already we already made it so
we're good
so where's your nobo
where did he go
oh I heard him yeah there he is
gotta wait for him to uh
yeah there we go okay
I still hope it gets game of the year
I know there's a lot of contenders but
this game is Just fantastic on a large
scale well it really depends like I just
want the best game to win if star field
ends up being even more mind-blowing
then I think Starfield should take it
I don't think balder's gate will take it
even though it's a fantastic game
uh there's just I feel like
it's a bit too specific of a genre for
people
like I it's not really for me because I
I'm not a big fan of turn-based con uh
combat it's just not my thing
but I do I've seen footage of it and
I've seen some
stuff about the story and it looks
fantastic
they really outdid themselves uh like
it's probably one of the best DND based
games
in the last decade
Stanfield
[Laughter]
Stanfield uh yeah I mean Stanfield might
take it
again I just want the best game to win
the one that really deserves it
and if there's gonna be a game like uh
I think
I would have been angry if Eldon ring
didn't take it
because it was just
objectively the best game that year
like God God of War was was really good
but Elder ring was just on another level
and it just did so much for the open
world genre
I just really you know what I really
hate about the game of the year uh
Awards I I cannot stand
Jeff Keeley well I I should rephrase
that I I it's not him as a person
he's because I don't know him maybe he's
a really nice guy to hang around with
but I really despite like he is so
biased Jeff Keeley is one of the most
it's like the Oscars almost
because
he is so he leans so much towards AAA
Western like Western Triple A games
he is very very biased towards that
particular side of gaming even though
there's so much more to gaming than
big triple like he he edited a special
trailer for gamescon
a few days ago
and it was all AAA Western like
realistic Graphics no indie games at all
like zero indie game stuff in there
it was just all the same stuff even like
all the games look the same as well
and there's just there's so much more to
gaming than just those type of games you
know
and for someone who runs an award show I
think you should be as unbiased as
possible and have a like a very wide
uh like taste in games
and it's that's why I compared it to the
Oscars for because for the longest time
the Oscars were so focused on Western
media
like just Western Blockbuster media and
stuff like that
meanwhile like there were so many good
stuff coming out of like Korea and
friends other countries were making
wonderful movies as well
but they just didn't recognize it at the
Oscars because it's not Hollywood it's
not a Hollywood production
it's like yeah but the Oscars should be
about the art of filmmaking
so I'm happy that parasite won
that year
like I think that was when was that last
year or the year before that
oh no soon you use a sand here I I don't
know I don't know what I'm doing I'm
just
he keeps crouching as soon as I reach
this ledge as it's really
it's really annoying
I don't know if I can use Ascend here to
be honest
yeah
this is how I beat the dungeon the first
time it's just keep trying to get
like grab onto Ledges and stuff like
that
can I get in here
nice cheesing
this dungeon was a pain in the butt yeah
maybe I'm supposed to do this in a
completely different way but
I like doing it this way plus climbing
is easy to do while I'm talking to you
guys
I don't have to pay attention to the
gameplay much when I'm talking
oh
I don't even know if I'm going to you
know what I'm just gonna drop down for a
moment
yeah there's no entrance up there I
think
let's go supposed to go from
downstairs I guess
uh
it's probably just an entrance somewhere
here that I missed
yeah it does have quite a few floors
anyone remember how to get in inside
this one
oh there is supposed to be a door down
there is it just that simple
is it just right that oh my God
oh it is closed
so how do I get in
she's with Hassan
well I was all the way up on the Upper
Floor just now and there was no
entrances there either
Glide from the from the top well I was
just at the top I wish I had the travel
Medallion right now
I could have made a travel point up
there
oh
you are right to Zoo
so it's it's he it's here
I was at the upper Upper Floor but
there's apparently an entrance
oh I gotta climb some more
look
see this is why I didn't stream the game
when I played it for the first time
I'm not good at them
it was just green ah there we go
this would have been so much easier if I
just had zonai technology at my disposal
oh
an elevator
yeah the first time was just like put a
super spring down boing uh go up put in
that put the next one uh like on another
floor and just rinse and repeat and
you're up in like seconds
this time it's not going to be that easy
unfortunately
uh
can't wait for DLC
I expected them to to have announced it
a lot earlier but apparently not
I mean they deserve a break although I I
doubt they are taking a break right now
oh do they have Rockets
they do
but I have to beat these guys first I
just use a rocket Shield
oh
you know what just
did it for me
uh yeah I can just use a rocket Shield
there we go maybe I'll make another one
uh
wrong one
Jesus
there we go
all right
I think a September direct would be a
perfect time for an announcement
oh yeah
I forgot they kind of take a break after
June
uh yeah I think I can just
no this one will burn so
I got I think two should be enough
so it should be over there somewhere
should I waste it now or should I I
think I should cross first
I don't want to waste my rocket Shields
yeah so it should be somewhere around
here
oh there it is
right or is that one oh no that's one I
already did
my spatial reasoning is not good
so it should be where okay is that it
should be
that should be it
get a better Vantage Point first
I think it would have been a better
sadder ending If Zelda stayed a dragon
oh I I totally agree
totally agree
I know people will be like what she's
been through so much already it's like
yeah but she doesn't remember being a
dragon so she's kind of at peace in a
way
I think
her choice to become a dragon to lose
her own
self
would have been more meaning meaningful
if that actually had the consequences of
staying a dragon forever
I think it's we don't always have to
have a sweet Care Bear ending sometimes
you can go a little bit darker with it
okay I might not even need the rocket
Shield
but I I will I will just use it
huh
[Music]
should be on the bottom floor right
yeah
hard agree for me too negated the whole
meaning of the sacrifice yeah
they do that in movies sometimes too
where someone makes a sacrifice and it's
like oh guess what they were still alive
at the end it's like well then the whole
sacrifice didn't mean anything
it was just a temporary inconvenience
let's go see Goro
skydiving is my favorite part of the
game
the views are brilliant yeah yeah it's
very very nice
just having the option to take on that
pose is really nice
what was what was inside it I wasn't
paying attention strong okay yeah I
definitely want that
I'll just drop a torch
he was just standing there with a giant
grin on his face
cow link Carter in the end for sure that
was a cinematic
cool cinematic piece
I think that's the my main problem with
the game is that I don't particularly
like this story in general that much but
I do enjoy the set pieces
which is a big difference obviously
there's a big difference between a set
piece and actually I'm going to capture
this I don't think I have footage of
opening the uh this door I'm not I might
need it sometime so I'm just gonna
quickly hit record
there we go
that's one for the record
and maybe also of the boss entering like
uh the boss showing up I don't think I
have that footage either
we've got to smash those rocks and
rescue Zelda
the story is made mechanics and setting
is amazing yeah yeah that's pretty much
my my thought my thoughts exactly
uh you just phrased it a lot more
uh shortly I I do have to quickly
have a bathroom break if you guys don't
mind because if I have to fight a boss
so uh yeah I will be back in like two
minutes or something like that
so stick around talk to each other and
I'll be back in a moment
foreign
thank you
I have I barely have anything to eat
do I have anything
yeah
so we're gonna
fight a boss with four Hearts barely any
food
no meals
and
pretty bad weapons although I could at
least view some stuff now
uh
oh
this is
I feel like that could have done a
better way of
using stuff but
abusing during a battle is pretty much a
no-go
uh uh what else do I have I guess
another one of these
that's better
[Music]
oh I should capture it
this footage as well
of the boss appearing
where's Zelda
thank you starstrider
chocolate
wait really does pen make a reference to
Cass
I thought no one no one acknowledged him
at all
which I thought was the reason why so
many people were pissed
I have to dive into the lore the the
text though
all right
foreign
there we go
yeah these weapons are not that great
oh
I should get I shouldn't get greedy not
with the amount of food I have
uh
what else do I have I want to save the
fish
oh wait no it's actually exactly one
hard
can you give me a met kid
you know welcome do you have any Med
kits on you
no tool and get
get away
we just gotta play the long game oh oh
I'm not gonna take any risks
oh you still you're still down
no
of course
figures
foreign
can you
okay you can ow what the heck
oh
I cannot eat these right now
still have a couple of stem bulbs
come on yes
foreign
oh wait I should use bullet time more
oh no not again the range on those is
ridiculous
laughs
uh
I think we're down to our last bit of
food
uh
it's gonna kill me in one shot if I
don't
eat everything
I have eggs
eggs
wait what
how did that not hit
okay
I don't remember what face oh it's just
him crawling on on the ceiling right
and then just throw ginobo in a loop
hoping that he will he will hit
something
uh oh
oh he's down
oh I should have more stamina this is
why you do shrines
oh
and I was too lazy to do any shrines I
just wanted to quickly go to the wind
Temple
and that's it
okay so he has a moment of
invulnerability
where you can't hit him
oh no
okay
come on League
no
oh
here I go
please hit him
oh I really I have so such a low stamina
foreign
actually how many all right plenty of
arrows how did I get so many arrows I
don't remember collecting any arrows at
all
I guess I just got them randomly from
from enemies
do the whistle they took out whistle
running
you bastards
wait
what
man
we've almost done
okay
still got full heart so I should be good
missed
hey
oh
come on buddy
I should use a spear oh that's not a
spear is that a spear yeah
oh actually this one does way more
damage
I just hate two-handed weapons
and he missed
oh come on come on
oh
where is he
oh no oh
I have eggs
and he missed again
let's go
where is he
oh
this should give me
plenty of hits yeah we got this
you know about with the safe yeah
oh I'm still recording I recorded the
whole fight well at least I have him
dying as well
you never know when that comes in handy
ggs thank you
oh I can also record the sage scene
even though it has subtitles which I I
wish I it didn't
just for editing purposes it's better
not to have subtitles
but at least I have to fight
that's the tune from age of Calamity
right
the the Overworld map theme
the whole on
yeah
it's gonna be funny to watch this back
because it it's also recording my mic
hey 100 Zelda
GG
thank you thank you
it's actually a very easy boss if you've
done anything in the game
oh
I I'd say queen gibdo is probably the
only one that's
somewhat difficult especially if you do
it in the early game
oh yeah it's uh
it's when you finish a mission it's not
the Overworld the Overworld one is the
other one the uh
and as a sage also a very good tune by
the way
I see your water
thanks for dropping by
did you know you guys did you guys know
you can Skydive into kogara's weak
points I did yeah but not the first time
I played the first time I used
uh
I think bone marrow is mostly but the
second time I knew about it
hey Silver Fox yeah I'm doing good so
this is the first you've ever heard of
any of this doing well how about
yourself
secret Stones demon Kings
haha you said Duty
so immature
see this part I feel like they could
have done something else because this
cut scene is told five times technically
if you count minerals version of events
which is longer and has more details so
I would have rather they
fleshed out the sages a bit more tell
them a little bit more about their story
and what they were up to and
see a bit more of their people during
this age
but instead no just let's just tell the
same story like five times
poop is funny it is a primal version of
humor that will never go out of fashion
however
we were no match yeah it was definitely
miss potential
like if you look back at other Zelda
games usually the cutscenes that played
there was like relevant to that specific
area or those specific people
because we barely know anything about
the sages nor the the Rito or the gorons
during this age
no I just I hope DLC will somehow flesh
it out but I
I'm not
getting my hopes up
it's a good thing the gameplay is so
good
yeah I would have loved to see the group
because there's so much that
love
clearly there was kind of like a divide
within the Gerudo you had evil grudo
followers of Ganondorf
but then later they also say like the
last free Village in the grudo region
has fallen I'm like well show it don't
don't tell me about it I want to see
what that was like I want to see why
like how they dealt with the Divide
because clearly there's a Gerudo Sage so
not everyone aligned with ganondor some
Gerudo
you know they
chose to stand with their King
and others didn't and at least in like
Ocarina of Time they kind of showed that
with naburu
it was like yeah I I'm second in command
of ganondorf's army or whatever and
I don't really align with his vision I
think what he's doing is not good so I'm
gonna try to overthrow him or something
and then you have kaome and katake
who punished her for it and there was at
least something there
Little Rock isn't that is it not a place
in America somewhere
I remember that from Zombieland
where is Little Rock
in which uh state
Arkansas
I see
Little Rock Arkansas sounds like a cool
place
I'd like nothing more than to smash the
Demon King
ston they should have given unovo a
beard in this one I feel like that that
would have made him an even cooler
character in this uh
I I was really expecting something like
that
when they didn't show specifically
didn't show him in the promotional
material I was like maybe he's like he
has like a giant beard now
it looks really badass but he just looks
the same
he's got the mess obviously in the
beginning
wrestler's mask
[Music]
which was pretty pretty cool
he has a little bit he's got a soul
patch yeah
that's not really a beard though
the size difference in their
best is so so funny to me
I think Twilight Princess was the first
game where I really felt like man gorons
are actually really
like it's a good thing they are on our
side because they are really really
sturdy and Powerful like they didn't
really come off that way in in Ocarina
of Time except for maybe darunia
but the rest of the gorons were kind of
goofy looking
but in Twilight Princess when they start
boxing with you and all that kind of
stuff and wrestling with you you're like
damn these guys they pack a punch
yeah okay Big Goron that's that's the
exception he could level cities like if
if Ganondorf would have wanted to
destroy the hylians in Ocarina of Time
he should have just brainwashed Big
Goron and just go down to demolish
kakariko Village that would have been a
very short fight
like the marshmallow guy from
Ghostbusters
like King Kong
are you Dutch yes yes I am
I'm as Dutch as a stroke waffle
oh
at least I got some footage out of this
I'm still recording
no my crystal meth
OD
I should have recorded this from my
previous video because I had some
footage that I needed of rock Rose
marble rock roast
[Music]
yeah the gorons meet Breaking Bad
you know but we need to cook
oh that was such a good series
I'm glad it ended though I'm glad they
didn't do The Walking Dead
style and just keep going and going
until everyone was sick of it they they
quit the show exactly when they needed
to
okay I got I think I got enough footage
I'm not going after after that treasure
thing that they talk about I'm just
gonna go straight for the next
dungeon although I'm not gonna be like
streaming for much longer
I don't think we're gonna do another
full dungeon but
when I get back from my short little
trip I will uh
I'll do some more streams because I'm I
need more footage
and there's no way I'm gonna do it again
like through Yuzu
better call link
good job it cured their addiction
could be a zoo
I I gotta be honest I haven't watched a
lot of Futurama
I should
because it looks like a show that would
be exactly for me
I don't know why I never but I've seen a
couple of like
like Random episodes here and there
what do the masks even do
I don't know
I feel like maybe they wanted to stay
Anonymous or something
or maybe it's like armor
like part of their armor I don't know
but it is interesting that the shika
made almost identical masks but more
like in their Style
but they are very very similar another
one of those weird connections
between the Zona and the chica
ah no worries blacklinks you're always
here anyway so
a wizard is never late
he arrives exactly what he means to
yeah if you'd wear the Divine Helm the
Shiga version they will put on their
Helm as well it's pretty cool
pretty cool detail
okay I can just skip all this stuff
how late am I to the party uh pretty
late but it's it's okay
we just did the the fire fire temple
from beginning to end
so yeah where do we go now
let's I always go just go to the nearest
Tower and
skydive
so it is very old print
I'm not old
I'm I'm the same age as Captain Kirk was
when he first got control of this the
the Enterprise
which is 36.
I'm in my Prime now is what I'm just
gonna tell myself
it's weird man sometimes seeing other
like people around me getting older
like
my friend having a kid and then suddenly
that kid is now almost going to high
school and you're like Jesus
how is that possible it feels like such
a short time ago when you first showed
me or told me that you were gonna be a
dad
you sound like you're 22. yeah
well I mean your voice doesn't change
that much between
like as soon as it drops to the level
that you will be stuck with for the rest
of your life and
I guess
70 or something I don't know
that's usually when your voice really
starts to change
I noticed that with James Earl Jones
I was like man he suddenly really sounds
like a grandpa
his voice really really changed and he
was already quite old when he recorded
like The Lion King and stuff like that
do you have kids uh no I do not I have a
dog
who I treat as my kid I go play soccer
with him
or football
but yeah we
haven't really decided if that's
something that we want
we are quite
that we are the type that really want to
just go out and
do things a lot
and as soon as you have kids that kind
of changes
it's already difficult enough to
bring the dog everywhere
maybe someday I mean my fiance is a
little bit younger than me so we still
have some time
where it's still responsible to
do it but I did I don't know
we'll see
children under pain yeah
it does seem that way to me
but you know to each their own I've
never been like my friend Charlie for
example when he was 19 or something or
18 he was already
saying things like I'm gonna be a dad
when I'm like as soon as I
move out of the the house and I have a
steady job I want to be a dad I want to
be young when I have kids so I can do
stuff with them and I never really had
that at all I never even really thought
about it
so everyone's different
what's this
oh Zora's domain
both dungeons I've already made some
like progression
oh we can defend gorilla town at least
that'll be a fun thing to do in the
meantime
wait you have chickens yes I have five
five chickens
we just bought a new one
two new ones actually because
unfortunately
two of my original five that I bought
died one of them got sick from
some unknown disease and the other one
was killed by my dog
not kidding
dog is not able to go inside the chicken
coop but there was a time when they
suddenly one of the chickens found a
little
whole inside like they could go below
the fence
like under like one of them at least
managed to dig its way out of the
chicken coop
and uh yeah
my dog was like Hey free lunch
well he played with it
which ended up being fatal
so my dog is now officially a murderer
I don't think I need heat
or
yeah like heat resistant
stuff when I'm inside town right now
let's set up the cannons
yeah rip chicken I thought at first she
survived
she played dead while he had her in her
mouth
and then at some point I put her back
into the coop because I thought she was
okay I thought she was just playing dead
because she started moving as soon as we
took her out like as soon as I told my
dog to let go
oh and then the next day we found her
laying by the side
so she ended up
if I knew that she was in pain that she
was actually I guess the the damage was
internal so you couldn't see it there
was no blood there was nothing and she
she started walking as soon as I put her
back into the coop and
if I if I had known that I would have
put her out of her misery obviously
because I don't like animals suffering
like unnecessary suffering and animals
is like the worst thing in the world to
me
but yeah we got a replacement
oh you got Ducks actually I want to know
are ducks fun to have as a pet some of
them some people say they're very messy
and loud
compared to chickens because chickens
are pretty quiet
they just kind of walk around and
they'll cluck like once in a while but
overall they're pretty quiet
they are really poopy yes yeah that's
what I read about them
yeah they are cute they're it my
fiance's favorite animal is ducks we
have our whole house is decorated with
chickens and ducks like statues of
chickens and ducks and she has like a
collection of those like rubber ducks
a giant collection like uh every time we
travel somewhere they will have those
rubber ducks like themed ducks
and like our whole house is filled to
the brim with them
what's the plan
okay I have to talk to the chief
I have a pet rock they're great they
never make a mess or noise
I imagine they don't
I'll see you later tuzu thanks for uh
dropping by and thanks for the uh tip
before about checking the map
they're solid pets oh my God
you guys are on fire
attacks oh yeah
at least I got materials out of this
lots of materials give me all your
I don't think I have to cook up food for
this because
they do most of the heavy lifting the
grooter themselves
weapons
ah yeah give me that give me that
you have any yeah I still have a
left man we wasted three weapons on the
boss
it's actually not as much as I I thought
no I want it I want the Groot of Shield
you can pseudo pet dogs using Ultra head
I guess you can yeah
folks uh Rays or C may see May raise you
have a tiny collection of rubber ducks
too
uh well our collection is pretty pretty
damn big
I don't have a picture of it here but
like we have one of those
closets like glass case like display
case
closets
full of them
and they're spread around the house too
so wherever I am in the in the house
there's always a duck watching or a
chicken
what type of run is this uh the type
where I just hang out with you guys and
talk
I don't run because I'm I'm bad at video
games
the only run I guess quote unquote Run
part of this playthrough is that I
haven't done any shrines so aside from
the original Three so I have four hearts
and no meals at all
uh spear goes east
I always put the cannon North
the sword troops
West
first playthrough no no
like three
and if I count recording random footage
from user then for I guess
because I started over a couple of times
for that too
I think you can choose this fight by
using a fan to go into bullet time and
then have fire fruits oh
to attack gibdos do I even have oh yeah
of course they gave me stuff shock
fruits and
topaz works too
I'm pretty low on resources though
the cannoneer
they will defend the North
I think you can fire the cannon once
here in the courtyard and then everyone
gets mad
they're like what the heck are you doing
that's super dangerous are you crazy and
then
oh wait I haven't
I should drop this one
no
actually I can
yeah
okay
let's do some practice uh swings
right
gibdo bones aren't they one of the most
powerful fuse objects but they break in
one go or something I I don't know my
name I don't know anything about the
stats
I already did
tell me about the enemy
uh
oh I just have to talk to her again
uh a fan you said do I have fans
I do
I will just deploy a fan then in a town
square
make no changes
wait how do I certified
we're ready right oh wait I just have to
talk to rijo again I guess
hmm they are
strong but brittle yeah
I think I already recorded this fight so
I don't need to capture this one
this part is pretty cool too as a run up
to the dungeon itself
get those The Walking Dead
still a shame that they don't scream in
this game
I guess I knew I didn't want to go all
the way with them
because I know he hates read ads it's
his least favorite enemy
and they're practically the same so
they both scream
foreign
speech
oh
protect our town
all right
uh yeah
I'll just wait for them to get into town
can I destroy the hive already
we're Canada they have to light up first
right
oh and now it lights up
there we go
foreign
I'll just destroy the destroy the hives
oh it's lit up
you guys take care of him
I'll see you starstrider thanks for
dropping by Edna good luck with your
ducks
the enemies won't stop coming until we
wipe out all the hives
I guess I do scream when you kill them
enemies have been spotted inside town
did they break through the gate enemies
are near
all we have to do now is clear out the
rest of the rest of the joke
are they in the Town Square oh they are
oh
I'm out of stamina again
well they they just took care of those
The Crawling ones kind of creeped me out
though
oh there's the flying ones
and there's not a lot of them
here give them
try farming the bones
it's a good idea
that's wood
where are they
uh
I'll just waste another one of these
nah
nah man
there's got to be like one gift though
somewhere left
oh check the map again
always forget to check them out
those dots those are those are the
troops right I think
let's not forget those
good
oh there's one there's one left yeah
you're right
I never checked the map during this
segment
oh oh now they killed him Jesus
they kicked its ass off off screen
right when I was about to go there he
just died of old age
yeah man I I totally got you
I mean it was your own people who uh who
just demolished them
yeah I I didn't even I also didn't know
they showed up on the map like it's such
a self-contained little section where
you just fight stuff I never even
bothered to check the map
The Voice
like those buildings for example those
were not there
in the previous game at all so where did
they come from why did they Rise Up from
the ground
the upheaval is weird man
some people
thought that when I set the castle
Rising wasn't Ganondorf again I was
doing
like
I guess I could could have phrase it a
little bit different in my video but
like obviously he is the one pushing the
castle up sort of and and the castle is
set to be a sort of seal
but I don't know if it's actually
sealing him as in because that's raru's
arm is the ones keeping him sealed I
feel like the castle was just built on
top of it to obscure the imprisoning
chamber itself
to just bury it with
along with ganondorf's corpse
just to keep people away from it but I
don't know if there was like a magic
like a magical seal to it as well
felt more like the
the castle was just a physical seal not
a magical seal
I do think I'm gonna have to buy some
clothing to protect me from the Heat
if I can
like raru's seal like the the green
spiral that's clearly like a magic seal
but the castle didn't exist yet
when that happened
so I don't know it always felt like a
bit Overkill to have two seals at the
same time
I feel felt weird at least to me
so that that's basically what I meant by
the castle Rising was kind of it didn't
really benefit anyone
I guess you could say it was ganador's
way of breaking out of the underworld
but I mean Lincoln Zelda got into the
impressing chamber without
having to write like raise a castle
clearly there there's an entrance there
and an X which means that also there's
also an exit
so if Picasso is some sort of magic seal
it would be the worst magic seal
imaginable
can I buy clothing although I don't even
think I have 100 rupees
yeah that's steep
yeah this one is heat heat resistance
I don't have a lot to sell either
I guess I'll just have to endure
oh yeah here's the
the Quest for the the heroine statues
which is not really a
a fun Quest necessarily it's a lot of
just putting things on things
yeah the pillar and the that unit they
they definitely seem like they were
connected in some way
which I will address in my new video
where we go into
the purpose behind it which is
I think what most people already guessed
it's probably like harvesting
ganondorf's
malice and turning it into into like
energy or something
I'm just running around aimlessly at
this point uh
yeah like I said I have so many I have
so many notes
I think I can just go there
ah let me just activate one of them I am
gonna
quit streaming soon though
because I have to get up early tomorrow
to uh go on the trip it's a six hour
drive so I I have to be well rested at
least
uh
okay
uh we are going to uh Mountain Rain
mountain range in France
the north of France
I don't know what it's called in English
it's like a national park
do some walking have some fun with the
doggo
Gloom probably didn't start seeping
until the seal loosened 100 years ago
yeah something like that
I mean the Calamity was also kind of
like malice
or Gloom seeping out
I thought it was a shame that they never
really addressed that part I know it's
pretty obviously the case where like the
Calamity and Ganondorf were
certainly connected it's just a shame
that they never really
address that in the story itself like oh
man so the Calamity was attached to this
guy all along it was just his Gloom or
his malice uh
forming into some sort of Specter or
whatever but they never really
acknowledge that
I think they should have
I think the closest we ever come to the
Calamity being mentioned is when Zelda
says like he once like when she talks
about link
where she says like he once saved Hyrule
from a great evil
that's about it
and yeah of course we have the tapestry
oh and in the school of course in the
school they
they do talk about the the Calamity but
they never really make the connection to
the current
predicament that they're in like with
the whole Demon King Ganondorf stuff
they they never outright say
that the Calamity and and Ganondorf were
connected
and Ganondorf himself doesn't even say
anything of sorts where he's like
I thought my Calamity would you know
destroy Hyrule or whatever they'll you
know you know what I mean
but he never really does
which is a shame
it would have been cool to hear
Ganondorf brag about like yeah I almost
got you guys
100 years ago
I killed all of you
except for a few people
uh
okay
I have to take that up
I think
I'm not gonna make that I can just
yeah it will reach
well they do mention or at least they do
it uh imply that ganondorf's
consciousness
is inside of his malice so he's
basically everywhere every that's
probably the scariest part of Calamity
Ganon at least in my opinion the the
idea that he's like
every little bit of malice is basically
Ganondorf staring you right in the face
obviously age of Calamity again not sure
if we're supposed to
regard that as Canon
but
he
he was able to time travel just by like
one sliver of malice was already enough
for him to just go into a different time
period
what
happened
maybe it's subconscious uh maybe
Maybe
oh
can I get it
yeah that that part we don't know if
it's like his subconsciousness or like
his full Consciousness because on the
other hand he does say like
aturaru when he gets sealed he says
thousands of years will pass in the
blink of an eye
which in the well like that that implies
that he's not aware of it for like in
his
experience it's just suddenly he gets
sealed and then suddenly he wakes up
again
he's just been unconscious all this time
but maybe that's before he devised the
plan to to create a phantom out of his
malice who knows
wait what am I supposed to do with this
there
what am I spinning
I think there's like a tower nearby
right
isn't there supposed to be like the
tower nearby
yeah I'm dying
I have some melons
I thought there was like a
something that you're supposed to spin
you went to the wrong one first oh
that's just great
where is the other one
that sucks that they put an order to it
I thought this was open world Nintendo
actually I can just oh no wait I should
have done that earlier
oh you have to activate the light behind
the tower yeah
so I want I you don't have to go
I don't have to go to the other one
first or do I
I'm confused now
I'll go back and take a look real quick
okay I'm gonna stop streaming very very
soon
it's already
close to midnight here
uh do I still have food no
yeah I gotta get some heat resistant
clothing before I start the next stream
dude
wow
missed wait is it missile
missile Salcido thank you so much
hey I love your content I ever sell that
wait hold on
or else I'm gonna die in game while I
read this
uh I have a theory starter Zelda is not
not longer a Reincarnation of hylia
considering
it's Sonia
oh considering it's Sonia at this oh
geez considering it's a Sonia descendant
and we can talk to hylia Via the statues
maybe Zelda was killed
or maybe a Zelda was killed
well the statues are it's definitely a
a weird
case with the the whole statues
I think maybe you guys were right
actually
you do have to spend this after it gets
hit by light oh well
but yeah the the stat first of all thank
you very very much that's uh that's so
generous of you
it is weird how uh raru and Sonia like
she gets her light and time powers from
raru and Sonia right because she's like
a descendant of those two
how else would she have both of their
powers
so actually the powers that we saw
before
in in breath Wild
indeed didn't really have anything to do
with hylia
except maybe the Triforce stuff that we
saw like where the Triforce manifests on
our hand but
man
it's so con it's so confusing now it
used to be just like yeah Zelda's
magical let's use magic powers because
she has
her bloodline is connected to the
goddess like doesn't matter how far back
that bloodline goes that magic Essence
will always be passed down
from generation to generation
but now we suddenly have the zonai
powers mixed in as well and Sonia's and
yeah I'm gonna have to think about that
one
like unless Sonia is also just a
part of the Zelda bloodline
she just happens to not be called Zelda
but like maybe her grand grandmother did
who knows
but then again like all she has is time
power she doesn't have light Powers
which is always that that's always been
kind of Zelda's thing too
like she summons the the light arrows
and
she has the power to dispel light
she uses like light powers to keep Ganon
yeah Ganon constrained in Ocarina of
Time
then again she also does have time
Powers as well because hylia has long
been theorized to be the goddess of time
yeah
Sonia descendant of hylia yeah that's
the big question we don't know
is
because we do have like a Zona hero now
too
it's or you know this whole thing is
just a reboot and we're we're
overthinking it and it's just a new way
to do it
I hope that's not the case well
I wouldn't mind if it's a reboot but
because then we can just let the whole
thing go like screw the timeline we can
just focus on the new
era of Zelda now
but it feels a bit cheap to just be like
yeah it's it's a reboot
that's usually not something Nintendo
does
yeah like a soft reboot or something
I can just go back to Gerudo town I'll
do this uh on the next stream
oh yeah the heroes aspect has a tail
yeah actually uh
magic tea
Majesty without the s
that is something like everyone calls
him a zonai right like the the heroes
aspect they're just like oh he's a Zona
hero it's like well the Zone I didn't
have a tail The Zone I didn't have red
hair
like it's not necessarily A zonai like
he has animalistic features to him sure
the which The Zone I uh do too like
they're basically furries right
but to just outright say he's a zonai
that's not really accurate
neither raru or mineral has a tail or
red hair for that matter or
you know his physique is he looks more
like lizard like
it's very weird
it could be that he is one of the last
of that race that we see in the depths
although those don't have tails either
actually I can travel there real quick I
think I have that light boot unlocked
I should have
because I do have the camera I think
I do have the camera on this save
did you look if you had a tail uh
well raru and mineral for sure unless
they like soup like the Saiyans like
tied it around their waist or something
underneath their their clothing I'm
pretty sure they don't have tails
they don't seem to have any tails
uh let's see or is it this one
which light root is it I think it's this
one then
but yeah the statues
like the the statues of that missing
race also don't have tails they just
have a butt
which you can
Ascend through
which we are going to do right now
before I end the Stream
yeah Ganondorf has a tail or Ganon I
should say has a tail and red hair
so it's it's very odd it seems to be a
completely different race altogether
because these guys also don't look like
the heroes aspect at all
their heads are different
also missile thank you once again so
much for the donation I feel like I
skipped over it a bit too quickly it did
start this whole rant about other lore
but yeah thank you so much
can't say it enough
yeah these guys don't have tails either
like I said they kind of look like
they kind of look like gecks
there we go you happy now
what is it they are holding is that a
tear or a secret Stone I should say
are they the original creators of the
secret stones
probably not
ow almost died right there
yeah if we do another one of these
streams I'll make sure we have some more
materials to work with because I am so
feeble right now
ouch
I'd like to make a video about these
guys one day but right now I I really
just I got nothing
it's just a missing race that we haven't
seen before a fifth
race
and they were pretty buff it looks like
I guess it kind of looked like the magma
a little bit but
those protrusions here don't really
match with the magma
the magma were pretty buff though
that's what you get for like digging a
lot I guess
yeah future depth DLC May shed some more
light on it
the
if the hero's aspect is a Zona then he
has to be a hybrid because he just
doesn't look like raru or miniru at all
which were the last of the zonai so
I also want to know what the heck is up
with their offspring did they have a
child yes or no because we see both of
them die essentially
but they they are supposed to have a
blood connection
but they never really
show any indication that they had a kid
at all
if they did have a kid they are terrible
parents
I guess they just leave them with the
the Royal servants
the Royal maid
the whole time
but I do think they should have fleshed
that out a little bit because now it
just looks like a plot hole
I know you don't always have to spell
out everything
but
at least give some sort of an indication
because raru is going to sacrifice
himself
you would think that
he would at least have something to say
about the fact that he's gonna leave his
kid to be an orphan
or that he's doing it so his kid can
have a future you know that that would
have actually made him as a character
even more intriguing
the fact that he's willing to make that
difficult choice
like yeah my cat my kid is going to grow
up without his parents unless Sonia
didn't die and she's actually still
alive
which I know we do see her grave inside
the Forgotten Temple I I don't think
I've been there yet on this
save file
no I haven't
because it's it's here
approximately
I knew I
do have the thingy a tower nearby
minaru well mineral went went into the
Chica slate or the Pura pad I should say
so we don't know for sure
just they good they could have at least
given us something
give us some sort of indication that
there was something going on there with
the Royal lineage and how that worked
hey it's ducky
hi I'm just here to say I love the life
of a column video it was wonderful or
what and I was wondering oh sorry I
totally misread that will you make a
part two
uh with other monsters at at some point
I probably will yeah
it's just that right now I don't have a
lot of inspiration for it
because if I'm gonna do another one I
want it to be at least as good or
I don't want it just to be something
like meaningless just point of views you
know oh that video got like millions of
views I gotta do another one
it was kind of like the whole reason
that video worked was because it came
out of left field
I didn't tell anyone I was making it
and it was just this weird little idea I
had in between my other videos
it was the type of video nobody no one
had asked for basically that I think
that's part part of the reason why it
worked and why people liked it
yeah raru does have a third eye and it
looks like the shikai
life has a Zone eye construct Maybe
yeah maybe
I was definitely never going going to
make another one before tears of the
Kingdom came out
because I felt like the other monsters
in graft world were not as
animated and interesting aspercoblins
you know but goblins are just really
they were such
well programmed well made
um enemy types
like they're monsters but they also have
a kind of like a cuteness to them which
I like little folks don't really have
that
and they're just very animated they're
so they're such they were such easy
characters to work with because they
already just do funny stuff without you
manipulating them to do them to like
their AI is just really good
because you know I've had some
suggestions like do like life of a lion
or I'm like well liners don't really do
anything they're just they just Pace
back and forth
because they're like
they're cool to fight but just as an
enemy to create a story around they're
extremely boring
I guess less of us would be the best
second choice next to the coblins oh
speaking of the goblins
there they are
and they saw me
oh there's more
life of a construct
I could also see if I can do something
completely different but in the same
format of a nature documentary because
it doesn't if I do something like it
again it doesn't have to be life of dot
dot dot you know it could also be
something else
you know maybe tackle some Wildlife or
do like a compilation video like that
there's more to it a nature document the
nature documentary than just
monsters doing it's that like their
thing
there are there are other options
because the original idea was like it
was uh
uh called even though the video itself
is called life of a goblin
the fake in Universe video like the the
the show is called surviving the wild or
something like that
which is kind of based on you know Bear
Grylls
uh where the other guy Ray Mears like
those old survival shows
those Bushcraft type of shows
[Music]
that's kind of what it was based on
with a little David Attenborough thrown
in there as well
oh the History Channel
yeah I could do an ancient aliens
that's actually not a bad idea I I could
I could see if I can do something with
that because you know we have the zonai
which are these
like alien god-like beings who came from
the sky that's
huh maybe I can do something with with
that
I'd have to have a mod of link with that
weird hair you know the the Einstein
type of hair the guy that says aliens
the alien meme you know
good
it would just it would basically be like
a mock-up because you know Ancient
Aliens twists so much of the truth
that's kind of like their whole thing
they if you actually look into what
Ancient Aliens claims like 90
99.9 of it is just complete nonsense
it's just not based on anything except
one guy who wrongly translated some uh
what was it again Babylonian texts or
something what is that what is that uh
that race called
or Not Race those that Civilization
yeah that's actually a really that's
actually a really fun idea something
like that that would work way better
than just doing another life of a
Cleveland type of video because I
already did that it would just be the
same but with the like a different
monster and my brain just doesn't work
like that I'm not like oh I will do
another one exactly the same because
views you know I'm
I care more about no not the Mayans oh
what was it called
something with a z I think it was
it's something like Babylonian or
no it's not Aztec either it's more like
in the
uh where Iraq and Iran are and stuff
like that now
so Sumerian yes it's not a z it's a s
yeah Sumerian texts like Ancient Aliens
is mostly based on
faulty translations of Sumerian texts
where they claim about like the Anunnaki
came from the sky and they they live on
a planet which orbits our solar system
once every I don't know
hundreds of thousands of years and then
they come they came here and they
created the pyramids and all that stuff
and like Ancient Aliens is just it's fun
bad because
on the one hand it's kind of harmful
obviously because they are lying to
their audience and they give a very
skewed version of History which is
also it's not only wrong
but it's also kind of insulting towards
the actual civilizations who built all
that stuff you know like the Aztecs and
the Mayans and the Egyptians they kind
of undermine that like no these
primitive people they were not smart
enough to create the pyramids or to
create these wonderful structures they
they didn't have the tools they didn't
have the they didn't have any writing
they couldn't have done this it's like
that's actually kind of insulting to say
that it's the legacy of these people
yeah it's kind of racist truly
but it is fun to make fun of Ancient
Aliens so I guess that would something
like that would work for for a Zelda
video too
but instead of you know aliens it would
be zonai you know what I mean
you play like X-Files type of music in
the background
like who put these pyramids here they
couldn't have possibly made it like this
it must they must have been using some
sort of anti-gravity device
to create these structures because
there's you know cranes what are what
are those
ancient zonai or whatever I I don't know
I I see potential in that
I definitely see potential in that
who who was the one who brought it up
first
actually curious someone said
Ancient Aliens and then that kind of
sparked like that like something in my
brain I was like that could actually
work
because obviously it's not going to be a
real Zelda Theory it's going to be
completely nonsense like way
overthinking things that's like the joke
the joke is that I go way too deep into
it or twist the the truth in a way
uh let me see who was the first one to
bring up I gotta thank them for it
uh it was when I was checking out the
statues I think
in life of a construct
uh let me see
I I gotta
quickly check that out or else oh yeah
Hiro it was Jairo who brought that up
ancient zonai
and then Grim Hawk said yes Ancient
Aliens
yeah Hiro was the one who said how about
a history channel-esque documentary
about ancient ruins
and then someone else brought up Ancient
Aliens and then Jairo said ancient zonai
yeah yeah you you two played off each
other
nah in a good way
that's a that's a really good one
I will write that down before I forget
it hold on
uh let me see where's my notes where are
my notes at
let me check real quick
[Music]
monster maze
videos notes
video ideas
ancient
aliens
mockumentary
there we go
it is there
it's a shame I cannot share my second
screen right now
because I have a few notes
what's my favorite Zelda game I don't
really have a
favorite
like it kind of changes there are some
games obviously that are higher up than
others like a top five but they they
always change
sometimes like
I will feel like oh Wind Waker was such
I will suddenly have this this wave of
nostalgia for Wind Waker and then it's
like oh that game was so amazing
and then I played Twilight Princess
again I'm like oh the dungeons were so
good and the story and oh it's my
favorite Zelda game now
so yeah I don't do favorites
my least favorite Zelda game would
probably just
be Zelda 2 I guess
because I don't have any Nostalgia for
that game at all
I can see if you grew up with it back in
the day
you you would probably have a different
opinion but I I didn't grow up with
either the first Zelda or the second one
not even a link to the past I started
with Ocarina of Time
well the Zelda CDI games they don't
really count do they they're not like
part of the actual
they were a fluke
I I'm also not particularly fond of the
3DS zeldas purely because of the art
style and the control setup like I just
don't like using the
the uh
what's it called
the stylus
to walk and attack and it just I didn't
I didn't really like it
Triforce Heroes actually I think I would
have enjoyed that game had I had the
opportunity to play it with friends
because I really liked four Swords
because I played that one with four
people back in the day with my cousins
and some friends and
even though it was a really short game
it was so much fun
same goes for
uh Triforce not Triforce Heroes uh four
Swords Adventures
Triforce Heroes it looks a bit more
goofy I guess
but I feel like I would have enjoyed it
had I been able to play it with other
people back then
it's a multiplayer game it's it's more
for the fun of it
it's just that the story was kind of
wacky
at least four Swords Adventures had a
pretty darn good story it's one of the
more complicated stories
of the whole Zelda series actually like
you have vati and Ganondorf at this in
the same game that's that's nuts
the fact that they dare to go there
I wish they would have done something
like that for 3D Zelda like have
Ganondorf and another big villain in the
same game
but yeah this is Sonia's grave allegedly
but we never actually see her die
Zelda is like raru
like Queen Queen Sonia needs you and
then she warps them away so the fact
that she says like she needs you and
plus she got like punched in the back
how how was that fatal
maybe they secreted her away
maybe she did survive and then see
although we do see like raru mourning
her right here in that cutscene so
it's I'm not sure
I thought she got punched it sounds like
a punch right
I don't even know if he has a sword
drawn in that cutscene
I feel like that would have been too
brutal to show so either way it's gonna
be a little bit they kept it a bit
ambiguous I guess what really happened
to her but what if she secretly survived
it would be kind of stupid it would be
kind of cheap I guess in a way
but it's possible
that would it would be at least a good
explanation as to why Zelda has
two ancestors who both die before they
seemingly had children
but who knows maybe DLC we'll see we'll
see
I I hope they will do more with it
oh she did get punched okay
I don't think I have
any of the cutscenes here
no
only the the first
few
he broke his spine dude well then you
can survive that so maybe she's not dead
after all
and they they wanted to keep her safe so
they secreted her away to a safe
location
like pretended that she's dead so
Ganondorf wouldn't come after I don't
know
again it would be pretty stupid
but usually when someone dies like
really dies they make no mistake about
it it's like it's or they make it pretty
obvious and here it was kind of like huh
that was kind of a weird sequence of
events
he just punches her it takes the thing
and then Zelda's like she needs you and
then they all teleport away
the idea of ganador smoking her with a
single punch is way cooler than a stab
let's be honest it is until you start
thinking about what his exact plan was
in that situation it is cool that
the Kitty just straight up death punched
her in the back
but I I did feel like when I first
watched that whole sequence like the
whole thing like in the context of the
whole thing
it was a bit weird
where it's like first Phantom Zelda
lures her outside throws a knife
because he obviously Ganondorf seems
like he
he felt like he was able to
uh
fool her into thinking that it was the
real Zelda
but they secretly already knew that he
had a puppet version of her
so then Zelda the real Zelda steps in
and she's like haha we did you really
think we did we hadn't
realized your deceit you're just a
puppet of Ganondorf and then Ganondorf
just suddenly is really he's just there
and he just punches her in the back I'm
like what exactly like when he devised
this plan
like was he accounting for the fact that
they would know that it's not really
Zelda so he's like you know what I'm
gonna distract them with a fake Zelda
who will try to kill her and if that
fails I'm gonna be right there behind
her in a bush somewhere and I'm gonna
punch him uh punch her right in the back
it's like I don't know man that's that
is some
weird planning if you really think about
it
seems like he improvised
I just imagined
ganador sitting somewhere behind that
edge that ledge of the castle or in a
bush somewhere just sitting there
waiting for his opportunity to sneak up
behind her and when he walks his
footsteps are like really heavy because
he's a big dude
so he he has some sneaky like his sneak
is like 100
he just sneaks up behind her without
like tiptoeing behind her and then
hunching her
right in the back
yeah yeah it is silly when you kind of
when you really think about it
it's okay it doesn't
like bother me all that much it's just
it's kind of funny which I'm not really
used to when it comes Ganondorf is
usually treated pretty seriously
like in Ocarina of Time there was
nothing like that
it was it was a lot more
serious I guess
same with uh Twilight Princess Twilight
Princess
his plan actually made a lot of sense
you really did get the feeling that he
manipulated this whole
situation
he drank the stealth potion yeah
yeah I don't know what I'm doing
actually I'm just walking around
randomly at this point I I thought about
activating this Tower but I forgot how
hard it is to activate this Tower
especially with
no hearts
just gonna try to gun for it see if I
can if I survive
oh
[Music]
oh my God what hit what hit me
what made those barrels explode one of
them shoot a fire arrow
I guess so
foreign
they never considered being infiltrated
the non-magical way just brute punching
just run past everything basically you
only have to reverse the the spike ball
and that's pretty much it
something hit those barrels
this was actually the first Tower aside
from the one that look at Landing that I
activated
on my first playthrough and I didn't
know you could push open the doors
so I spent this whole time being like Oh
no how do I get in there trying to hide
from all the enemies
they was like oh you can just
oh
[Music]
foreign
Lookout Landing is always open I think
I'll see you Devin I'm actually gonna
turn off the stream any moment now I'm
uh I'm kind of done I'm tired
it's past midnight now
but yeah thank you uh so much and have a
good one thanks for dropping by
remember when people were theorizing
Ganondorf was good oh yeah I never I was
never on board with that
I could see it with a sub villain like a
uh
uh Zant type of villain who at the last
moment is like yo you know what no
I'm done with you
you treat me like garbage
I'm switching over to the light side but
Ganondorf himself nah
Ganon punch
yeah I guess he did do a wizard punch
but now it's not called The Wizard punch
what is it called in Smash because it's
the wizard kick and the
I don't know what the punch is called
it does have a name
because all the attacks have a name but
warlock punch that's the one yeah
because that's totally a thing he does
well he did now in tears of the Kingdom
when he punched uh Sonia I wish he would
have done the Doria
and then she just drops down like a
like a ton of bricks
oh thank you black links I'm I'm glad
I'm I managed to be somewhat
entertaining while stumbling in these in
these games because I'm not I'm not
really that great at improvising speech
that's why I
you know I I would never be able to do
this stuff that HMK does for example
where he just sits down in front of a
mic and just like yo yo guys
he barely has to
study his script meanwhile I'm for every
video I have to take like 20 takes per
sentence to make sure I I say it the way
I want it to
well 20 is a bit of an overview well
there have been sentences where I have
to do 20 takes but usually it's like
four five maybe
also I hope you recover fast black links
sorry to hear that you're sick
sending you my best
I'm sure I'm sure you'll recover soon
go to sleep you zombie YouTuber says
chapsy who just became a member for 24
months
wait 24 months really
you've been a member for that long
Holy balls
man time flies
but yeah what do you have Tom
why did I throw a bomb
that was not necessary
Where is the
where's the mine
am I even close to it
and then in central mine should be
close to here
oh there's a light root here actually
I'm gonna activate this light root and
then I'm gonna call It Quiz uh quits
Quest I'm gonna call it Quest you guys
man everyone's been sick lately
Auto build time
we have to beat Koga first and blah blah
blah
so yeah I think I'm just gonna leave it
at that guys
thank you so much for joining it's been
fun theorizing with you guys and talking
and uh
maybe I'll do one more stream before my
actual video goes up or maybe a short or
both we'll see
I have a lot to write
like I said the notes
are I have a lot of notes
like two pages worth of notes and I'm
gonna have to turn that into a full
script so it's gonna be a long video
I expect like 30 minutes probably
but yeah thank you so much thank you
again to misael
for his very gracious donation really
awesome
thank you so much and thank you everyone
oh and thank you to Jairo and uh
uh oh God
Grim Grim Hawk yeah
thank you to Hyrule and Grim for the
suggestion about the Ancient Aliens
video
yeah it's a rest time thank you Saban
and uh thank you everyone and I will see
you all next time bye-bye